dans ce tome rihanna merci nous
accueillir dans votre maison à winnipeg
ça fait plaisir
vous avez étudié en chant jazz vous avez
fait le tour du canada avec vos
nouvelles chansons
cinq tournées en europe vous allez faire
diriger par ce que vous vivez de votre
musique à temps plein comment vous
expliquez que vous avez réussi dans un
contexte où vous êtes en minorité dans
une mer anglophone à arriver à une telle
preuve ça plus de l'aide du mentorat
comment vous avez vécu c'est bien pour
moi la chose la plus importante à
travers tout ça ça a été ma communauté
non seulement ici au manitoba mais aussi
dans l'ouest canadien au clair je pense
que la clé c'est aussi que qu'on va pas
faire les choses de la même façon on va
voir comment pu rejoindre notre public
anglophone aussi comment ont pu faire
venir les amateurs de musique anglophone
vers la musique francophone c'est
quelque chose pour doigt qu'on doit
faire chez nous puis je pense en fait
que ça nous enrichit et moi j'ai fait
plein de spectacles avec des groupes qui
chantent en anglais puis on m'a jamais
dit si on m'a jamais demandé de changer
la langue dans laquelle je travaille
c'est jamais une question
c
pas
beaucoup aimé votre premier album north
à perth et électro ça sonne un peu comme
d'ariane moffatt le retour du louis jean
cormier là dedans
notre intention d'être inspirée par
l'histoire de mu si je mens j'aime
lesquels ben oui je sais que ton âme est
certainement celle des artistes qui j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup écouté puis ce que je
trouve le fun c'est que un c'est souvent
nos influences sont pas nécessairement
celles qui sont repérés par le public
alors c'est qu'ils ont commencé mais qui
tous j'ai beaucoup utilisé en jazz et
puis j'ai quand même puisé énormément de
mes connaissances dans ce genre de
musique
si j'écoute beaucoup dit veille orange
et que beaucoup james blake aucun l'om
voilà des artistes de partout monde
merrimack et b c'est quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup écouté donc ça
ça je pense que ça c'est ça se
synthétisent dans ce qu'on produit en
tant qu'artiste mais la majorité des
artistes que je connais on écoute de la
musique de partout puis de toutes sortes
de différents genres aussi
brille pas tellement dans
certaines fois qu'ils avaient foi
lavoine y avait daniel lavoie c'est la
chanson franco manitobaine nom est
ailleurs les choses ont changé pitié ces
artistes la folle avoine daniel lavoie
ccc les artistes ses piliers de mon
enfance passée les piliers de la musique
francophone dans l'ouest certainement
pilote je pense que que nous on a
maintenant la place pour que quand on
s'aventure ailleurs justement pied qu'on
fasse de la musique selon une influence
à nous en ayant aussi ses sites
historiques l'aide sur laquelle on
puisse mettre debout je trouve ça je
trouve c'est vraiment un privilège en
fait comment l'amour le français ça
semble être l'amour de votre vie
comment vous l'avez cultiver cet amour
il n'y a pas fallu travailler trop fort
c'est en maternelle s'est vu qu'on a
tellement besoin de protéger notre notre
langue il faut qu'on n'en ait un
approche un approche d'amour au pied
d'un lien culturel un lien pas parce que
c'est le devoir mais parce que c'est ce
qu'on veut c'est parce que ça fait
partie de qui on est alors un pour moi
j'ai dû faire ce travail-là de de
reconstruire ma relation avec la langue
à une relation dans l'amour inondant la
honte aussi parce que c'est on s'est
souvent remarqué pour notre accent cela
si souvent dire que tino tournures de
phrases sont bizarres aux gains que
c'est que c'est pas comme ça qu'on dise
en français en france et ans en 10 à 15
de ses puits puis ça fait qu'il ya comme
beaucoup d'insécurité linguistique puis
à beaucoup de monde par rapport à ça et
puis il ya vraiment fallu félicite et je
m'en fous je m'en fous de ce qu'on dit
déclenche pas ou qui je m'en fous de ces
du fait que je parle clairement oui je
pense différemment pis vous voulez
savoir quoi quand je parle avec ma
famille c'est encore plus différent pis
quand je parle avec mes amis de l'eau
casey oui en tendant à toi et je m'en
fous moi je trouve ça moi je trouve ça
bien moi je trouve ça génial
puis ceux qui sont curieux trouve ça
cool aussi
alors je pense qu'il faut juste en a eu
[Musique]
beaucoup
st
qu'on passerait
santé
[Musique]
se retrouver